he is an actor screenwriter and director
best known for creating the rocky and
Rambo series he was evicted from his
apartment and was homeless for three
weeks before getting into the film
industry he became the third man in
history to receive nominations for Best
Original Screenplay and Best Actor for
the same film he Sylvester Stallone and
here are his top 10 rules for success
what in this whole world turns you on
challenge I really just I just love I
love it you know I love being told no it
just means yes no to you yeah what
turned you off lack of enthusiasm really
turns me off my point is I'm pursuing
something that nobody looks too happy
about it
but we're just looking out for your
interests I appreciate that but maybe
you're looking out for your interests
just a little bit more I mean you
shouldn't be asking people to come down
here and paint afraid on something they
paid it still ain't good enough I mean
you think that's right I mean maybe
you're doing your job of why you gotta
stop me from doing mine cuz if you're
willing to go through all the battling
you got to go through to get to where
you want to get who's got the right to
stop you I mean maybe some of you guys
got something you never finished
something you really want to do some of
you never said to someone something and
you're told no even after you pay your
dues who's got the right to tell you
that who nobody it's your right to
listen to your gut and ain't nobody's
right to say no after you earned the
right to be where you want to be to do
what you want to do you know the older I
get the more things I gotta leave behind
that's life the only thing I'm asking
you guys to leave on the table is what's
right we were running behind schedule
and I had to shoot a montage oh my god
this this montage would have taken like
five days so what I did is I I came in
there brought everyone into one big room
all the dancers and had three cameras I
took one camera and just stayed with
John Travolta and I worked with him and
the rest I said to everyone just dance
and do whatever you want cartwheels
I say catch it all whatever and then I
sent a camera down when they're making
the stage we just
regular light I said just shoot what you
can just no sound nothing and we put it
all together and save four days of
filming but none of that absolutely zero
was choreographed Wow in the funny I say
okay John just do this yeah cut do this
cut and then I swear to God and then the
other dancers were just over there in
the corner maybe scratching doing a
somersault stretching and you put it all
together now maybe it's a metric of a
myth
yeah it's like so there are no rules
crazy yeah I first met Bob shot off in
Irwin Winkler and I believe I was there
on on a casting call so we're talking a
little bit and I guess I really wasn't
right for the acting part and on the way
out I said oh I don't know if it matters
but I do a little bit of writing because
really I said yeah I'm ready this story
this uh I have this thing about
wrestlers and I might do something about
boxing Wally as well bringing around and
I thought if I hadn't stopped on the way
out you know that's why I tell all
actors writers don't give up keep
talking eventually you might hit a nerve
somewhere to go ah come on back and if
they didn't say come on back or bring it
later and let's see what you've
developed I wouldn't be sitting here and
what I'll try to do is I'll join in it
on so on a legal pad I'll go goes here
sees his mother goes to the store
because so I'll have like ten things of
beats where he's going now gets on a
horse go swimming bum bubble and I do
that and I know in my heart 80% of it
will be no good but you're getting
through the screenplay you're getting it
done because the rewrite is always more
fun and much more enjoyable it's I don't
believe people should look for
perfection or even 50% profession in the
first draft it's always going to be kind
of this like a child scribbling but you
did it and the main thing for me is to
once you have that accomplished when
they say in to you can do it in two
weeks three weeks again maybe 10% will
be good but
you now have the sense of accomplish you
did it and the rewriting process starts
and that's when the fun begins
originally when I brought the script to
them they were fairly enthusiastic about
it the one thing they were not
enthusiastic about was me playing the
part and I really can't blame them at
the time Ryan O'Neal I was a candidate
Burt Reynolds Robert Redford Jimmy Caan
and they all you know we're at the top
of their game so I could see it but
there was something inside of me that
that you know this opportunity is never
going to come around and I really wasn't
used to money and I had no idea of what
I would be missing but the temptation
started to come forward first it was
twenty five grands and a hundred
thousand dollars ago I never heard of a
hundred thousand because I had had like
a hundred six dollars in the bank and
like I said I had to sell my dog and
things were not looking very very good
my $40 car had just blown up so I was
taking a bus to work and was still it
didn't matter I wanted to stick with it
then went up to 150,000 or 75,000 went
up to 250,000 now my head was starting
to spin and it went up to three hundred
thirty thousand and probably I heard it
what was three hundred sixty thousand
and I thought alright you know you've
really managed poverty very well you've
got this down to a science you really
don't need much to live on I had like
sort of figured it out so I was not in
any way I used to to the good life song
you know what if I know in the back of
my mind if I sell the script and it does
very very well I'm gonna jump off a
building and if I'm not it there's no
doubt about I'm gonna leap in front of a
train I'm gonna be very very upset so
this is one of those things you just
roll the dice and you fly by the
proverbial seat of your pants say I got
a try it I got a just to it I may be
totally wrong and I'm retaking a lot of
people down with me but I just believe
in it right e night I almost approached
it like exercise I get up maybe at 4:30
in the morning
takes an hour to get going and then I'll
start to write about maybe three hours
and then it becomes repetitive in the
next day I get up and even if I don't
feel inspired I'll sit there for three
hours until I get the brain says okay
you must start to produce something so I
try to write quickly and I and I follow
up pattern just the way you would be if
you were in the Army or whatever and
then that gets me through it quickly
some writers will take a year to you
every one is a different process but
that's what I do I write better in the
morning
right my friends I use I used to write
at night all the time when I was but I
found that everything everyone died it
was dark and creepy there was a really
horrible I was like very depressing then
I realized Edgar Allan Poe used to write
at night now I figure out what if you've
never had anything like today I would go
okay I'm selling I can't give up the
house right you know but if you don't
have the house you don't have anything
and you're just sitting there and go
okay I wrote this for myself and I don't
even know if it's that good but if it
it's obviously someone likes it I'll
regret it I know I'll regret it night
and I bet I say it once a week if I walk
around as if thank God really oh all the
time
all the time it's like you did one thing
right in life but you can do a thousand
things wrong just do one thing right you
it makes up for the other 999 mistakes
sometimes give up something to get
something and I thought I didn't have
any money so I had no phone
I painted my windows black so I didn't
know if some was up the Sun was down all
I know is I have to write and I wrote
and I wrote it it was very bad
it wasn't good at all but it would every
day it was getting better and better
like like a machine like a muscle until
finally the idea for Rocky King so the
idea is you must fail a hundred times to
succeed once it's that's part of it you
know one succeeds the first
it's learning how to not get
disappointed with failure to understand
failure
you only learn when you fail you don't
learn we you succeed here to some photo
skills that but we fail that's what you
learned so that's how I learned by lucky
I was a failure in New York and that is
the reason I started writing which may
be successful I had to teach myself
early on expect to fail expected coveted
welcome it is going to happen but don't
is that a permanent statement but
somewhere along the line you changed you
stopped being you you let people stick a
finger in your face and tell you you're
no good and when things got hard you
started looking for something to blame
like a big shadow let me tell you
something you already know the world
ain't all sunshine and rainbows it's a
very mean and nasty place and I don't
care how tough you are it will beat you
to your knees and keep you there
permanently if you let it you me or
nobody is gonna hit as hard as life but
it ain't about how hard you hit it's
about how hard you can get hit and keep
moving forward how much you can take
hey keep moving forward that's how weird
it is done now if you know what you're
worth the glottic get what you're worth
but you gotta be willing to take the
hits and not pointing fingers saying you
ain't where you wanna be because of him
or her or anybody cowards do that in
that a Jew you're better than that
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because Daniel Danny Frankel
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of Sly
Stallone 10 rules mean the most to you
is most applicable to your life and your
business leave it in the comments below
I'm going to join in the discussion
thank you so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon